e
prolongation aux négociations
pour en accoucher.
La création d'un fonds dédié
aux dégâts irréversibles causés
par les effets des changements
les plus vulnérables.(a(a(a(a(a)
Un moment historique,
qui marque avant tout le début
d'une justice climatique
ré
en développement
depuis plus de 30 ans.
"La création d'un fonds n'est
ununune question de charité.
Il s'agit clairement d'un
acompte sur l'investissement
notre avenir communet un investt
dans la justice climatique",
lance la ministre desiqiqiqiqiqs
du Pakistan.
Pour cette activiste du Togo,
l'humanitéanananananananananana.
- Mais déjà qu'il y a un fonds
qu'ils reconnaissent qu'il y a
responsables d'une situation
et d'autres quenenenent
être soutenus pour
continuer à survivre.
comme je le dis toujours :
l'humaniagagagagné.
- Un pas en avant sur la
question du financement, certes.
selon plusieurs,
nananananant la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre, essentielle pour
climatique à 1,5 degré.
être parvenus" déclare Frans
mamamamamans de l'Union
européenne.
Car l'Union européenne
ont fortement insisté pourququqe
mention quant au retrait graduel
de toutes les énergies fosmbmbmx
États pétroliers a
visiblement fonctionné.
"Si nous n'accélérons pas la
production de nos émissions,
planète ne pourra compenser
pour les peseseseseses dommages
que nous subirons", dit-il.
Tout n'aura pas été perdu
de ce fonds. Mais plusieurs
grtitititititions restent sans
réponse: qui contribuera
au fonds et qui pourra en
des énergies fossiles,ieieieieit
si elle sera à l'ordre du jour
de la COP qui se dérouleraisisi,
un État pétrolier. Ici Elisa Se,
Radio-Canada, Charm el-Cheikh,
en Égypt